hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
thorsten welt ich stehe heute nicht in
meiner küche
ihr wisst ja ich habe vor einigen wochen
einen sponsor aufruf gemacht weil ich ja
in meinem shop bald auch kurse anbieten
möchte und ich möchte er dort auch
kinder kochen backkurse anbieten die
dann eben gesponsert werden sollen damit
das ganze für die kinder kostenlos
bleibt
und da haben sich jetzt ganz viele leute
gemeldet nicht nur firmen sondern auch
privatpersonen und es freut mich
natürlich unheimlich dass ihr euch alle
dafür engagiert und einfach auch die
verantwortung übergeben möchte dass wir
mit den kindern das zusammen machen
können und ich werde heute einen kleinen
kurs machen mit kindern
wir haben allerdings heute nicht die
richtige küchen location dazu ich zeige
euch auch gleich wo wir hinfahren und
deswegen habe ich mir überlegt einfach
ein paar donuts mitzunehmen und die mit
den kindern zu dekorieren
und wenn ich auf instagram verfolgt weiß
dass ich das totale dollar fällen bin
und immer gern in mannheim
hier weist a100 bin und da die
leckersten donuts einfach sind und ich
packte jetzt einfach ein paar donuts 1
probier auch gleich menschen die karima
ist halt mitarbeiter darf wird auch
probiert mein lieblings oder kokos
tonart und ich würde jetzt sagen wir
steigen ins auto und dann zeige ich euch
wo wir hinfahren aber vorher muss ich
euch noch was ganz lustiges zeigen
guck mal hier da hängen ganz viele fotos
da ist die familie mit im donau kipping
ich mit sechser box ist a&p steffens und
hier ist noch das war mal mein nachbar
der stammt zwar aus aber der richtig
lebt und der band spielt heute übrigens
eine ganz wichtige rolle bei dem projekt
was wir heute machen aber das verrate
ich einfach gleich
also ich stets in mannheim im
kinderzentrum und ich möchte jetzt heute
einfach hier die kinder besuchen und ich
habe vorhin schon gesagt dass ich von
einigen firmen unterstützt wurde und
jetzt hat mir zum beispiel die firma
küche so petz papier zungen tattoos
mitgegeben und die kann ich jetzt gleich
hier auf der kinderstation den kindern
verteilen und werden mit ihnen gleich
die donuts dekorieren
er hatte bmw hier ein bisschen mit den
kindern die donuts dekoriert und ich
habe hier mit der rosa zusammen war ich
hier im radiostudio und haben wieder
aufgenommen fußball kann stufe ich meine
zuschauer mal erklären was radio roms
ist also radio roms ist ein projekt des
gesundheits treffpunkt mannheim in
zusammenarbeit mit der
universitätsklinik mannheim
und wir haben hier ein radiostudio und
wir sind jeden dienstag und donnerstag
für die kinder da wir machen radio für
die kinder aber auch mit den kindern
heute dürfen die kinder zu uns kommen
wir zeigen den wie man eine radiosendung
macht richtig professionell
die dürfen interviews so wie sie das bei
dir gemacht haben und einfach aus diesem
klinik altern ausholen und die kinder
die machen es auch wirklich gut der mir
alle fragen gestellt was durch fragen
gibt jetzt hab ich so eine frage und
zwar der bund hat hier auch eine
bestellung oder so eine rolle was ist
denn da ja der für den tälern ist dieser
schirmherr und wir sind natürlich sehr
froh dass es so ist weil immer
prominenter halten
oberster stelle sieht ja natürlich und
die kinder fragen immer dann kommt der
bühne und wir wollen ihn sehen
das können wir natürlich nie versichern
der kommt aber tatsächlich manchmal
vorbei nur zweimal ja so in etwa und
besucht uns und lassen wir natürlich
sehr sehr froh dass wir ihn haben als
schirmherr also uns total
vielen dank dass ich heute hier sein
durfte danke du hast ein super gast also
seid richtig spaß gemacht und den
kindern hat auch spaß gemacht das schon
gesagt fährt auf jeden fall mal wieder
vorbeikommen
bald ist fünf jahre
ihr habt ihr jetzt kurz gesehen was wir
mit den kindern gemacht haben das hat
echt richtig viel spaß gemacht die
kinder haben ganz toll mitgemacht und
auch das interview hat mir richtig spaß
gemacht die kinder man richtig
interessiert daran was ich mache und
vielleicht gibt es da so was auch bei
euch in der nähe und ich finde wirklich
schön wenn man einfach hingeht und so
ein bisschen den kindern den tag versüßt
das war heute für mich ein richtig
schönes erlebnis und hinter mir sind
auch fast keine donuts mehr übrig die
sind alle schon weg gefuttert
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat und wird mich freuen wenn
ihr meinen kommentar da last und wir
sehen uns dann einfach beim nächsten mal
wieder falsch